war is up guys I just found out I am
adult aid
what is up guys I just found out my mom
is homosexuals
[Music]
whoa ease up guys it's a da gate and I
guess this is a good time to address
this question
awesome so if you guys ask the answer is
yes hey what's going on guys today we're
doing another giveaway we give it away
5,000 V bucks all you got to do to win
is leave this splat button subscribe and
leave a comment the Declaration of
Independence backwards that's all you
got to do to join now let's begin the
video a few weeks ago I made a video on
fortnight and nothing has changed
basically it's still the same the
absolute state of YouTube gaming is very
much still I love these thumbnails
they're so good it's basically the SOI
boy equivalent of a thumbnail and I know
what you're thinking listen I am happy
for my man le a I am a glad to see
really good content to thrive on this
platform as always okay he makes the
best content you know here we have a
video called their Superman challenge
well Superman is in fortnight or you
best watch 25 minutes to find out that's
how we're doing that that is Howard I
would grab the clap look at it is it it
is it don't move don't move
we did it guys we completed every single
change points that was a lot of fun and
if you've got any more challenge ideas
do leave them down below I guess there
isn't a watch that flash is in for at
night nope no it isn't the hook the hook
is in for tonight I must watch this 22
minutes and 35 seconds right now this is
not clickbait guys this is what the
content is it's reflecting the content
just like my videos are always 100
accurate lately that the trend of
fortnight clickbait has been what's
inside you have a concept of something
what's inside it a free present from
Epic Games what's inside oh I best watch
to find out what could it be
ah what is it inside I need to know what
is in that package what did they give me
and why does it take 21 minutes to find
out here we go guys this is what you
look like I've actually gone ahead and
taking the glider from the very first
twitch prime set and add the in for a
complete twitch prime look which is
awesome and we are gonna gear up use
this brand new outfits and go ahead and
try and go for a bit - boy yeah if you
like the back to epic game - giving us
free skins give it a big fat thumbs up
as well without further ado let's check
out these new skins let's check out our
brand new pickaxe as well and try and go
for a win
if you ever liked anything at any time
in your life leave a like on this video
right now if we're talking about what's
inside things here we have opening the
bunker what's inside what I want to know
is what's inside Ali A's hacked he I
mean he's wearing it in every single
video he must be hiding something
underneath there ah what could it be
I have some ideas but I will keep them
to myself yes we are underneath the bunk
we're inside inside this new secret
bunker it doesn't look like there's
anything in there like all your content
got you Ali I know a lot of you think oh
this is just for kids ali-a it's just
for kids and that's why it's so popular
excuse me you don't know ali-a like I
know le a he's delivering some of the
hottest content on YouTube he's gone
into there come on sneak in sneak in
go on go inside inside in you go in you
go
let's just destroy it a wider way oh oh
five cubes oh forget this will be a six
wait a minute if he's at five kills and
if he gets one more
then that means I'm just memeing I think
Ally seems like a really good dude we're
just joking we're just joking it's just
a joke I see a lot of people being so
amped up about his content and how bad
it is and they get old I don't know I
just
if you check at Ali's Twitter replies
everyone is just so mad it's just a game
who cares if you compare Ali A's content
to so much else on YouTube he's honestly
it is like one of the least bad at least
and I think he gets the most [ __ ]
probably just because he's one of the
biggest ones so I feel a little bad just
want to say Ali you're in Europe I can't
come I can't compliment people it's it's
beyond my comprehension but some people
just get so mad about their the whole
fortnight means I am so angry the absurd
for my quick weight that I cannot sleep
the sheer number of content creators
that fake videos is dwarfed only by the
millions of people who watch daily and
do not care I just don't understand I
just do not understand this on any level
and it makes me feel like an alien thank
God we have brave people like drift or
standing up for a fortnight clickbait
this man absolute Saint finally that
someone that delivers the topic of
fortnight clickbait in a serious manner
because it is very serious I just want
to watch really good fortnight videos
but there's all just clickbait
everywhere what am I gonna do
moving on let's see what ninja has been
up to the number one fortnight streamer
like do not bully people how are you how
are you not in [ __ ] school you kiss
your mother with that mouth
it's called you kids call you kiss your
mother with that [ __ ] mouth huh
how are uniting school well it's like
asking all your audience
because the [ __ ] youth do not make
fun of anyone you justify it by like oh
there's a bunch of people doing it it's
okay it's not okay [ __ ] you kid you're
adopted oh the level of white knighting
it's almost like he's playing Skyrim
ninja is clearly not like this anymore I
know it's really unfair to edit an old
footage with you but it's also very
funny he's clearly a lot better these
days okay I don't wanna I'm just naming
guys stop taking it so seriously I'm
sure he's laughing as well by the way
guys did you know Santos is in for
tonight Santos is in for tonight - most
cancerous things that I hate the
the whole world that everyone else seems
to love decided to combine just to spite
me thank you appreciate it
uh-oh Sanders got arrested I guess part
two of Avengers infinity warriors cam
sold now sorry kids no more Thanos just
like there's no more content from Ally
aid playing fortnight now that he
deleted fortnight this made Ally a
delete for tonight he referring himself
in third person just to clickbait
himself
that's de Deus
No
[Music]
Oh No
who will I spend 25 minutes watching
daily damage let's see how summit is
doing I'm [ __ ] down dude I'm [ __ ]
dead dude I'm [ __ ] the end these say
these battle royale type games really
brings out the best of people doesn't it
you know I can't relate to this
whatsoever because I've never let out
something embarrassing at an editing at
an intense gaming moment that just
wouldn't happen to me okay I'm not some
pathetic screechie gamer that likes
video games for children control my
emotions okay judges does not happen
okay did I mention fairness is in for
tonight yeah oh my god smash like right
now guys if you enjoy dancing for
tonight just as much as I do
you've probably seen this meme already
but it's so funny these one like equals
one strip videos got so out of hand that
some dude just thought hey I can just
bring my 13 year old sister in here and
she can get naked four views on YouTube
yes what a great idea basically me and
my 13 year old sister could be playing
for tonight and if I get a kill she has
to take something off of me
one day later I really do understand
I know it's not a porn you know what I
mean you know what I mean what's about a
government and literally a government
law saying restrictions on screens and
bans on for instance fortnight has an
age limit of 12 fortnight this becomes
such a problem therefore parents that
they they even propose a government ban
what a great night here thanks for
tonight no IP the ball that's really
really weird and there you have it that
is the absolute state of YouTube gaming
oh for tonight thank you for tonight if
you guys want to find out about an even
better game than fortnight check out ass
coming out May 15 parade
[Music]